un g7 de emergencia dedicado enteramente
a afganistán reunidos en una cumbre
virtual bajo la presidencia de reino
unido- las siete grandes potencias
occidentales eeuu canadá japón alemania
francia italia y reino unido buscaron
acordar un enfoque común para gestionar
las evacuaciones en curso washington
planea mantener la fecha de finalización
de sus operaciones militares y
evacuaciones para el 31 de agosto así lo
confirmó el presidente yo waiting
ahora mismo estamos en un punto de
completar las evacuaciones para el 31 de
agosto cuanto antes terminemos mejor
16 mis soldados estadounidenses están
ayudando actualmente para evacuar a los
ciudadanos estadounidenses y afganos que
se consideran en peligro en el país esto
es mientras se asegura el aeropuerto de
kabul para permitir que otros países
realicen sus propias operaciones de
evacuación varios países entre ellos
francia y reino unido- han manifestado
su deseo de que se amplíe el plazo del
31 de agosto pero finalmente no se
acordó ninguna prórroga
pues sí la condición número uno que
ponemos como g7 es que los talibanes se
deben garantizar el paso seguro de todos
aquellos que quieran abandonar el país
hasta el final hasta el 31 de agosto e
incluso más allá
el grupo talibán no lo ve así unas horas
más tarde el portavoz se pronunció en
sentido contrario pidiendo eeuu que
nueva cuenta a los afganos más
cualificados
no hay que animar a nuestros expertos
afganos ingenieros médicos analistas ya
los que se han formado aquí a que se
vayan este país necesita sus habilidades
no deben ser evacuados a países
extranjeros hasta otros temas para el g7
definir una hoja de ruta sobre cómo
relacionarse con los extremistas
el elíseo pide que rompan completamente
los vínculos entre los nuevos amos de
kabul y las organizaciones terroristas
añadiendo que se les juzgará por los
actos y no por los anuncios en cuanto a
la defensa de los derechos humanos de
los derechos de la mujer en particular